we're stuck with the monsoon for now and
it is not going away this week in fact
we have a
chance of storms just about every single
day look how high the humidity and the
dew point even more so the dew point
when it gets to 60
we know there's a lot of juice in the
atmosphere 88 degrees
sunrise was 5 40 and sunset is 7 54. we
had some thunderstorms last night
brought up to three quarters nearly of
an inch of rain lone mountain and a
hualapai
cheyenne and 215 almost half an inch
floyd lamb state park a third of an inch
and a little bitty cell right around
henderson dropped about a quarter of an
inch of rain this was between around
eight and ten o'clock last night
mesquite's muggy and warm at 87 degrees
indian springs a little cooler at 77
86 in prompt look at death valley still
at 102
i just double checked that number 83 in
sandy valley in searchlight laughlin
near 90.
cedar city 68 72 in kingman and kingman
you'll be looking for thunderstorms
again today
so especially over in arizona we're
going to be hot and muggy all week
chance of thunderstorms every day right
through the weekend
and temperatures will drop when the
chance for storms increases
and you'll see that in the eight day
forecast once we get to the weekend
so the flow is still very strong
especially centered around the four
corners
and we're just kind of on the western
fringe of it already starting to see
some showers pop up here over the
california line
on the other side of the front valley
104 today it's going to be hot if we get
enough sunshine
clouds are always the variable during
monsoon season too
about a 30 chance of storms late today
into tonight
104 tomorrow 20 percent chance once we
get to sunday into monday
looks like a wave of energy could tap
into a lot of moisture in arizona
to bring a better chance of storms we're
going to have to really watch those days
and of course we will with our 8 news
now weather team
6